Everybody remembered where they were, what
they had been doing, when the SCP Foundation
revealed themselves to the world.
It was an event that had so fundamentally
changed the lives of every person on Earth
that it became pretty hard to forget that
momentous, horrible day.
Even though, for most people, it had begun
as a day like most others.
Dane Moss had been at home when it started.
His roommates were talking about buying an
air hockey table for their place, something
to liven up their Saturday nights.
Even as he half-listened to them discussing
it, Dane figured it would never happen.
He was right, of course, but he never could’ve
anticipated the thing that stopped it.
All of them had stopped and fallen silent
as the news report came through.
A group calling themselves ‘The SCP Foundation’,
previously responsible for the containment
of anomalous objects, entities, and phenomena,
had declared its new intention to exterminate
the entire human race.
Dane’s split-second belief that the broadcast
was a Cloverfield-style viral marketing stunt
for a new movie was quickly disproved, when
the ground started to shake.
Unbeknownst to him, the Foundation was not
only real but had detonated nuclear charges
along the back of SCP-169, an enormous ancient
arthropod that’s body had made up an archipelago
adrift in the ocean.
The detonation caused The Leviathan to stir,
resulting in massive earthquakes and tsunamis.
Dane was the only one to make it out of the
apartment alive.
Elsewhere, Joe Rees had been grabbing a coffee
on his way home from work.
He briefly overheard the news report, but
barely paid it any mind.
Then, waiting for his flat white, wondering
what the hold up was, he caught part of a
conversation between two people behind him.
“What is that thing?”
one asked.
“I don’t know, but its face is pure nightmare
fuel,” the other replied.
“A bunch of pictures of it just appeared
on everyone’s socials, it’s really freaky
stuff-”
A sudden shriek went out from a number of
the coffee shops patrons.
Joe noticed a towering, humanoid shadow being
cast by something behind him; its arms were
stretched out, disproportionately long…
and it was attacking the two people behind
him.
Acting on an instantaneous fight or flight
response, Joe ran, without looking back to
see SCP-096 slaughtering everyone that had
seen its face.
Around the same time as the Foundation’s
ominous announcement was played over every
news channel on the planet, Rene Hudson and
Sky Soto had been on a date.
The pair of them had been enjoying hanging
out, playing a few mildly competitive games
at the bowling alley, but there was still
something unspoken lingering in the air.
Neither Sky nor Rene really felt any connection;
they liked each other’s company, but that
was as far as it went.
Although neither one of them knew how to broach
the subject for fear of hurting the other’s
feelings, and in the same vein, neither one
of them could have predicted the commotion
that would happen next.
The noise came from outside, the deafening
screams followed by a flood of people running
for their lives.
Hundreds, if not thousands, were fleeing,
any that fell over in the street being trampled
underfoot by everyone behind them, human beings
moving like a mass of ants, clambering over
each other to get away from a gigantic, ferocious
lizard.
Despite the news broadcast declaring themselves
and their intentions to wipe out all humanity,
nobody on the ground would ever be able to
comprehend just why the Foundation unleashed
SCP-682 and allowed the Hard to Destroy Reptile
to slaughter innocent civilians in droves.
While they didn’t know it – or may not
have agreed – Sky, Rene, Dane, and Joe were
all lucky to have survived the initial anomalous
onslaught unleashed by a rogue SCP Foundation.
It did little to ease the pain of being displaced
from their homes, forced to migrate across
the country to join camps of other survivors,
made refugees by anomaly attacks, and the
efforts of apathetic agents of the Foundation.
And of the four of them, not one could ever
have predicted the shared fate that awaited
them.
During the months in the wake of the Foundation’s
opening assault on mankind, Rene and Sky had
mostly stuck together.
They had moved further and further south,
managing to stay safe.
Neither one had thought about their awkward
date in months, they were just grateful to
have someone they knew to stick together with.
Meanwhile, Joe and Dane were hopping from
one refugee camp to the next much the same,
moving north and eastward respectively.
After deploying their first wave of anomalies,
the SCP Foundation’s efforts had shifted
to primarily focus on Groups of Interest that
could pose a threat to their plans.
While organizations with knowledge of the
anomalous, like the Global Occult Coalition,
were among the first in their crosshairs,
the civilian population was left living in
fear, but unscathed.
That is, until the Foundation began targeting
the refugee camps.
One of their tactics was to unleash SCP-2241,
a seven-year-old boy with reality warping
powers, into survivor communities to act as
a living weapon, destroying the larger refugee
camps.
It was the increased frequency and ruthlessness
of the Foundation’s attacks on human survivors
that forced Sky, Rene, Dane, and Joe to unknowingly
converge on each other.
Camps for survivors started getting smaller,
consisting of only a handful of people, in
the hope that this would make it easier for
them to avoid detection by the Foundation.
Arriving and hopping off the back of a jeep
with only the clothes on their backs, the
four strangers exchanged uncertain glances.
They had been brought to an abandoned dock,
the wreckage of an overturned cargo ship laying
on its side in the harbor.
Shipping containers were scattered all around,
looking as if they had spilled out of the
boat onto the dock.
The driver of the jeep hadn’t told them
where to go from there, instead, he had just
driven off without so much as a word.
The four of them looked around; Dane seemed
particularly unnerved at being so close to
the water, despite it having been months since
the Leviathan settled back to sleep.
Suddenly, one of the shipping containers burst
open, and a broad, flannel-shirt wearing man
stepped out.
His face was buried beneath a thick beard,
a shotgun resting against his shoulder as
he approached the group.
The man’s stern, stony expression quickly
changed into a wide grin, as he jovially and
unexpectedly pulled Dane into a hug.
“Welcome, my friends!”
the man roared with laughter.
“Welcome!”
“Um, who are you?”
Sky asked.
“Of course, allow me to introduce myself,”
he responded, letting go of Dane who needed
to catch his breath after being squeezed so
much.
“My name is Jovanius, for safety I watch
over this camp,” the man announced.
“Camp?”
Joe asked, looking at the wreckage.
“The Foundation has been getting more zealous
with targeting those of us that are left,”
Jovanius explained, gesturing for the four
to follow him as he walked back towards the
container.
“So, we’ve had to take a less conspicuous
approach to surviving.
Splitting the camps up into fewer people,
dispersing everyone around a bit more and,
of course…”
He swung open the door to the metal container.
Inside the cramped space, there were two bunks
either side, one above another, making four
in total, along with a sleeping bag on the
floor.
“Staying in places the Foundation wouldn’t
think to look,” Jovanius continued.
“We have to sleep in here?”
Rene asked in disbelief.
“Better for avoiding detection,” the camp’s
protector replied.
“Otherwise, the next camp along is only
twenty minutes away on foot, over in a warehouse;
if you’d rather go there.
But be warned, they have rats.”
Although it came with a brief adjustment period,
the group quickly acclimatized to living in
the abandoned dock.
Each of them came to appreciate Jovanius’
efforts to keep them all fed with what few
rations they had.
The four of them started calling him Big Joe,
referring to Joe as Lil’ Joe to avoid confusion.
Of the group, Dane seemed to have the hardest
time adapting.
He was something of a conspiracy theorist,
anxiously talking about other great disasters
throughout human history and wondering if
the Foundation had been responsible for them
all.
Sky felt a little sorry for him, so they decided
to humor his theory that the eruption of Mount
Vesuvius in Pompeii was also the SCP Foundation’s
doing, despite occurring all the way back
in 79 AD.
Through all their various concerns about surviving
in this anomalous, apocalyptic world, Big
Jo seemed to have a talent for keeping the
group’s spirits up.
Whether it was by recounting them all with
folk stories or turning bland food rations
into more flavorful meals, he made the four
of them feel safe, especially with his weapon
never far away.
That is, until one evening.
A glowing red streak shot through the air
not far from camp, catching Jovanius’ immediate
attention.
It was an emergency flare, sent up by the
neighboring camp at the warehouse.
Something was wrong.
Grabbing his shotgun and urging Sky, Dane,
Rene, and Lil’ Joe to stay put, Big Jo left,
running off into the growing dark of night
to try and help.
The whole group stayed awake waiting for their
protector to return, the next hour feeling
like an eternity.
By the time he returned, the sun had fully
set outside.
Even by the low light of their lamps inside
the container, it was clear by his face that
any and all optimism had drained out of Jovanius.
“There was nothing left, all of them were…
gone,” he explained, unable to believe what
he had seen.
“There was this… oil everywhere.
Corrosive, like an acid, just burning through
what was left of them.”
Trying to regain some semblance of composure,
he urged the group to get some sleep, reassuring
them that they would be safe for the rest
of the night.
Not one of them realized just how wrong they
were… or that they’d never seen Jovanius
again after they fell asleep.
Rene was the first to discover he had gone
missing, screaming with panic, waking up Sky
and the two boys.
After they had calmed her down, Sky tried
to rationalize what was going on.
They were as worried about Big Jo as the others,
but couldn’t afford to lose their nerve
and potentially attract the attention of a
Foundation kill squad.
“It’s the Foundation,” Dane babbled,
terrified.
“They’ve found us.
They’re closing in, oh man!”
“Relax,” Sky replied.
“All of you chill.
There are other camps nearby, maybe Big Jo
went to check on them too?
See if what had happened to the warehouse
group happened anywhere else?”
“You don’t think he would have told us?”
Lil’ Joe retorted, seeming to be the least
concerned about Jovanius’ whereabouts.
“We were asleep.
It’s not like him to wake us.
He knows we’d worry,” Sky answered.
“What if he’s dead?”
Rene sobbed.
“Don’t say that!”
they replied.
“She’s right though.
He left his shotgun right here,” Joe interjected
again.
“Whatever got the warehouse group killed
him, it's obvious.
At least I don’t have to go by that stupid
nickname anymore.”
“What the hell, man?”
Dane yelled.
“You joking at a time like this?
What’s wrong with you?”
There was an uncomfortably long pause.
Everyone in the container turned to look at
Joe, leaning against one of the metal walls
with his arms folded.
The other three were all thinking the same
thing, although Dane was the first to say
it aloud.
“You killed him, didn’t you?”
“Don’t be ridiculous!”
Joe chastised him, backing away slightly,
betraying his own little hint of fear.
“You and Rene are hysterical; you both need
to calm down and-”
Before Joe could finish his sentence, a withered
arm reached out of the wall and grabbed his
throat.
It looked like the rotting, decaying arm of
a corpse, protruding out of a puddle of black
mucus that now seemed to be spreading across
the inner wall of the container.
Rene screamed in horror as more of the black
substance oozed from the arm, melting away
Joe as it held him helplessly in its grip.
It was then that a face peered through the
oily patch smeared on the wall: the nightmarish
visage of SCP-106, the Old Man.
For a second, Sky thought about trying to
help Joe, they could’ve pulled him free,
but it was already too late.
The corrosion was spreading, it looked like
it would melt them too if they so much as
touched it…
Joe was gone.
The remaining three of them burst out of the
shipping container they had called home, afraid
for their lives.
“What the hell was that?”
Dane screamed.
“Oh man, I knew it.
They’ve sent a monster after us.”
Sky barely paid him any mind, their attention
grabbed by movement nearby.
Someone had started running the second they
had exited the shipping crate; they had been
watching from a distance.
“Hey, stop!”
Sky yelled, about to run after them when…
“Sky…”
Rene’s voice was cracking under the weight
of her terror.
Turning around, they saw it.
The Old Man stood behind Rene.
It looked even more grotesque under the low
light provided by several distant fires in
the ruins of cities the Foundation had destroyed,
giving the horizon a hellish glow.
SCP-106’s withered, lipless face bore his
rotting teeth, locked in a skull-like grin;
it gave a sense he was gaining some twisted
enjoyment out of what he did next.
Rene had been frozen to the spot, sniffling
in fear, her legs rigid and locked in place.
Until the Old Man clamped a hand over her
shoulder, then she cried out in a blood-curdling
shriek of agony.
More of the black ooze spilled from his emaciated
fingers, dripping down her front while Sky
looked on in terror.
Rene had been the one person who had been
with them the entire time, from the moment
the Foundation unleashed hell.
Every camp they moved to Rene was in the same
one with them.
The pair of them may not have been a couple,
but she had been the only constant in this
anomalous apocalypse.
And now, this sinister SCP was killing her.
Fighting their every urge to grab Rene and
pull her free, Sky instead let themselves
be led away by Dane.
Choking back tears, they ran alongside him
in the direction of whoever had been watching
them.
The shadowy figure was just about visible,
although definitely still close enough to
be heard.
In the dark, there was the sound of a fall,
accompanied by a pained grunt indicating that
whoever had been watching the container had
tripped.
Both Dane and Sky knew this was their chance.
Together, they lunged at the figure before
he had a chance to scramble back to his feet,
with Dane pinning the observer down by his
wrists.
That was when the light of the burning city
on the horizon illuminated his face: he was
the jeep driver, the one who had dropped them
at Jovanius’ camp to begin with, the only
other person – apart from Big Jo – who
knew where their camp was.
“You!”
Sky declared.
“What were you doing spying on us?”
“I have nothing to say to you,” the man
spat.
“Answer their question!”
Dane yelled, slapping the man in the face,
although he didn’t seem to react.
“What is that thing chasing us?
Why did it kill our friends?”
“You might as well tell us,” Sky told
him calmly.
“After all, once that monster catches up,
we’ll all be dead.
You were watching expecting a result, right?
Had to make sure none of us made it; not that
there’s anyone left for us to tell if we
did survive.”
“He’s with the Foundation!”
Dane gasped, catching on quickly.
“You had them send that corpse-thing to
kill us, man?”
“SCP-106,” the undercover MTF agent corrected.
“And yeah, it’s here because we sent it.
You all went underground, hiding in your little
camps.
We had to look even closer to find you all.
Ungrateful, all of you.”
“Ungrateful?”
Sky exploded, enraged and offended at the
idea anyone could justify all the death the
Foundation had unleashed on the world.
“What, you expect us to thank you for hunting
your fellow human beings to extinction?
Dropping nightmare after nightmare on us?
And we’re meant to be grateful for that?”
“None of you understand what we’re trying
to do,” the Foundation agent replied without
a hint of remorse.
“What we’re trying to do is bigger, more
important than your mundane little lives.
The only way we can save humanity – from
It – is by wiping you out.
Before either Sky or Dane could ask what ‘It’
was, a gloopy, oily smear appeared on the
ground.
Clawing his way out of it, the Old Man reached
for the MTF operative, disintegrating him
like it had done before.
But the agent barely reacted, didn’t cry
out like Rene or Joe had.
He was still, even as he was melted by the
slimy black secretion of SCP-106; it was as
if the man couldn’t feel the pain of what
was happening to him as he died.
A splatter of the same corrosive mucus spread
onto Dane’s sleeve.
Freaking out as it began burning through his
jacket, he desperately tried to wipe it off,
only to smear it, spreading the dissolving
substance further and crying out as he felt
it eating into the palms of his hands.
SCP-106 climbed up out of its oily puddle,
dropping the disintegrating MTF agent.
He disappeared into the corrosive pool, vanishing
from sight like he’d fallen into a ditch.
Sky backed away, their eyes locked with the
sunken stare of the Old Man, feeling their
legs begin to freeze in fear, just like Rene’s.
“G-gun…”
Dane rasped, laying at SCP-106’s feet, slowly
succumbing to the same fate that had befallen
the others.
“Big Jo’s… gun…” he rasped again.
With the last of his strength, he used his
arm to grab the Old Man’s ankle, howling
in pain as more of the black substance oozed
from the monster’s wrinkled flesh.
Sky turn and raced back towards the shipping
container, hardly daring to look over their
shoulder.
Every movement, every tiny shift of shadow
they detected in the corner of their eye,
filled their mind with images of the Old Man
baring down on them, wearing that sadistic,
skeletal grin.
Sky pulled the heavy metal door open, using
all their strength to get back inside.
Their arms were numbed, trembling so much
with terror that it was like they weren’t
attached properly.
They fumbled about in the dark, their fingers
brushing up against the weapon, resting in
the corner where Jovanius had left it.
Pulling on the pump, Sky turned, the gun raised,
knowing that the Old Man was right behind
them, and pulled the trigger…
It gave a redundant click; it was empty, no
ammunition – the gun had been just for show.
SCP-106 reached for the weapon and pulled
it from Sky’s hands, the metal of it slowly
melting as it was coated in the tar-like corrosive
substance.
Recoiling their hands from it, Sky went to
dash for the door, only to feel the Old Man’s
bony, burning fingers hook into their back
and drag them towards the greasy black stain
he was leaning out of, pulling them into his
domain.
The world had been a living nightmare since
the Foundation had revealed itself, and unleashed
an anomalous apocalypse on humanity.
But SCP-106’s pocket dimension might just
have been worse…
Now go and check out “SCP-5000 THE FULL
STORY COMPILATION” and “SCP-106 CONTAINMENT
BREACH” if you’d like a little more of
this particular flavor of existential nightmare!